[Music]
all right hi everyone so yeah my name is
Andy threaten and I work for a company
called cigar me and under the hood of
our product then we've been using quite
a lot of them asynchronous Python to
make things work faster but also to
reduce the number of dependencies so
that it can be just installed on any
user's laptop so yeah for this tutorial
there's a few things that you can be
setting up so the first one is MongoDB
if you want to play around with MongoDB
just install it from the website and
also on top of your basic anaconda
install then there's the distributed
package and also Luigi package and then
a a io HTTP timeout decorator and motor
so all of this stuff's on the slack
Channel if you want to take a look there
so yeah what is for garmi what we're
going to cover so we're going to look at
how how can you use all the processes on
your machine when you are running a
simple data side script and we're going
to demonstrate this by doing an image
processing algorithm over a gallon art
gallery data set so in this case what we
what we I'll just show you quickly what
it looks like what the final output
looks like so this is our source of
garni and here we have a a scatterplot
of the x and y parameters and these x
and y parameters have come out of a
t-sne algorithm and so the idea of that
is to cluster the images and find out
them so that similar images then you can
use the this we allow people to then use
our tool to help them tag and annotate
images but it could equally be used for
generating machine learning algorithm I
mean it hasn't it hasn't worked that
great but there's there's some
interesting and separation going on here
ok so back to the tools and the next
thing we're going to take a look at is
how do you and consume social media data
as it's being produced so if you go to
stream on them Wikimedia you can
actually see all the changes that are
being made by people to Wikipedia so
this you can see the scroll bar here on
the left hand side right hand side just
increasing increasing as data comes in
so handling this kind of a dataset
either producing it or and or consuming
it is a great application of an
asynchronous frameworks
and then obviously when we are
asynchronous we've got to not waste any
time sort of blocking and waiting for
things so we need to then be able to
write this data straight into a database
but not necessarily wait for a
confirmation let the exceptions be
handled somewhere else then we're going
to take a look at how do you create a
simple task scheduler loop so typically
if you had to make something happen once
every second you might create a while
true or something simple like that but a
synchronous framework gives you a lot of
power to do things like this also then
it this is an interesting one because
all of these async frameworks whether it
be thornado async IO or concurrent
futures is kind of a thing
all of them sort of purport to give you
a timeout against the function that
you're calling but what as we'll
discover things are not that simple
thing - you can't necessarily time
outside a function and for an exception
if it takes too long it may just carry
on running in the background anyway
then we'll look a little bit at what the
architecture of the jupiter notebooks is
and then think about how can we use
WebSockets
in the most simple way cuz when I was
trying to learn WebSockets with tornado
I always saw these really big examples
with all the different routes and built
and hopefully in this talk I'll show you
a super super simple one that everyone
can understand what's going on so yeah I
guess to start off with some definitions
of what we're talking about so
concurrency means that more more than
one thing is happening at once space
and that's not actually it's not
synonymous we have a synchronous
asynchronous is the Anthony move
synchronous but concurrency is not if
neither asynchronous nor synchronous it
could be one or the other out like and
then also we have this concept of
futures so I like to think of a future
is like an IOU from whatever system for
a piece of data that you've asked it to
produce by running a function so these
things are called promises in JavaScript
so if you ever learn JavaScript you'll
end up using promises and futures are
very similar really you can wait for
them and you can do things when they're
finished then you've got this concept of
an executor so these are these are a set
of threads or processes that you just
create put there and then send some
tasks to them so rather than say
creating a process or running a script
for a task you're actually creating a
holder process that then you can throw
throw some things into it so it's bit
like a road it's it's there after all
the cards of garden effectively and it
has been a number of lanes as well so
you can say how many how many processes
how many threads that determines how
much capacity it's got and then yeah as
I say it doesn't it doesn't move around
anywhere even when the cars are all
driven through then you you can close it
down or it maybe just stays there
depending on the framework so in the
standard library we've got two two
executors the thread pool and the
process pool
and out then in this little example here
then we open up a thread pool and we can
we can submit to the thread pool and
then future dot gun will return those
them those faults straightaway but if
I'm if I actually go to my notebook then
I run this function yes return this fold
so wait a little bit
I run the next one and it went and it
returns was true so you can see in the
background that's being run and the
future is holding the status of that
particular function call
so yeah just going to sort of reiterate
we haven't had to do anything in our own
business logic to the check whether it's
complete or not then we also have
executed that map for processing lists
of data so this allows us to send the
whole lot of data off to be processed
and get back some futures for it so this
is the next example we were processing
some prime numbers or finding out
whether these numbers are prime or not
now
yeah so then all of the numbers come
back and burn then so we're having to
call so yes I be the function itself is
printing out whether anyway click Arial
then for the other thing that's really
useful is to use the as completed
iterator so what this allows us to do is
to chuck a whole load of data to be
processed and then get it back in the
order that comes comes back to us so
here it's we I have no idea which which
order these particular functions will
return in so we have 0 2 3 4 1 this time
but it will be different every time so I
guess for the first exercise that if you
want to get involved in that it would be
to perform this t-sne analysis on this
art gallery data set so it's kind of
slightly contrived but what we're doing
here we're downloading a CSV file then
we're downloading the images we're
replacing the images and converting them
to linear rays of pixels so the same
operation as was done in the previous
talk and then we're performing this
teeth teasing t-sne analysis
so
so yeah if you've downloaded the as
anyone who wants to kind of got hold of
the notebook if they want it either me
but it in the notebook folder we've got
this Ashmolean dot pi file and here
we're running through we're getting the
data just with standard library requests
so this is this is completely basic
stuff really pulling back the data we
exam requests and aggregating it
together
so once we've them aggregated the data
from the requests library then then we
can process the images one by one now
the question is how do we make this work
with multiple processes so and moving on
to sort of the the answer then
we only actually had to change the run
section of the implementation so all of
those functions that we had didn't need
to change at all and we could just
parallelize it by first creating a
process Paul executor submitting all the
tasks to to be processed and then going
through them as completed and calling
this result function so results on the
future
gives back the results of it but that
can be that is slightly different
whether it's a tornado future or a
future coming from concurrent our
futures then finally we sort of submit
them back into the pool to be processed
again wait for the completion of the
data and then run the t-sne algorithm
there's no parallel version of TS any
available in scikit-learn
so yeah there's not much we can do about
that there is a sea a sea based version
that we could try if we wanted to get
really fast
so to conclude this sort of part of it
then we're able to run the processing
across multiple machines we don't really
need to change the code and we could if
we want to open lots and lots of threads
to pull back the images off the internet
so what is a think and why why would we
do it with a think well I think is
really a change in the flow control of
the program so this can be somewhat
tricky to understand so I've got a
little sort of analogy what what is
asynchronous Python and so let's say I'm
trying to make some toast and make some
and fry some eggs at the same time then
I've got I've got all these different
tasks that I need to do in parallel with
one another so that at the end of it
I've got hot toast and hot eggs on top
of it so there's a few ways we could do
this
so procedural way let's say I've got a
really crappy old toaster like this then
I can't I could try and toast the bread
but I've got to watch the toaster while
it's real it's doing its job so how am I
going to get everyone's toast cooked as
well as their eggs so I'd have to maybe
half cook the toast turn it off and then
go cook the eggs intent so and this is
somewhat analogous to what you would do
what we're doing in the original version
is if we're not using parallel processes
then when it comes to multi process then
you've almost got you've got two two
people cooking the breakfast together
and you can communicate with each other
and yes if you do it right it'll works
fine but it relies on you being able
to run two different processes on your
machine I mean multi-threaded maybe
that's me with both my hands cooking
both the toast and the eggs yeah I can
do it my brain has got to consciously
switch between looking at the toast and
looking at the eggs so this but this
context switching is the whole point
behind asynchronous programming as in
normally if I open 500 threads on my
computer then the computer itself is
deciding when to context switch between
those threads when to when to leave one
of them running and jump to the other
one and actually as we'll see that
they're really really good at that so
some of the reasons that people maybe
give four eyes and async programming
grapes are a little bit bogus in some in
some respects so in an asynchronous
methodology then I I'm throwing away my
old toaster and I'm getting one of these
then a toasters that can that can detect
whether my toast is cooked or not and
this was actually developed back in 2005
way before the internet and things so
don't let any Kickstarter startups to
tell you otherwise
and then then maybe I want to cook my
eggs carefully so I get myself a Heston
Blumenthal one degree precision culture
so if I put together the best things I
can have to cook my breakfast now I can
simply set off my toast set up my eggs
maybe I have time to set up a vacuum
cleaner to go read the paper and eat my
breakfast so that's sort of the idea
behind a synchronous program
we're setting all these things off but
it's me that's doing it I'm not having
to use two hands I've got all my
concentration on one one task at a time
but I'm setting these things to run in
the background and then coming back to
them when say they beep so the toaster
beats the the egg poacher beep and I can
just go back up on the event and get on
with the job so what is that idea of
cooking breakfast how do i express that
programmatically so we we send a task
off to be run that requires no
processing at all on my machine we get
back in an acknowledgment so say we're
firm MongoDB we're getting back just
MongoDB saying yes I've received
something but we're not getting back
what they've what longer D be done with
that piece of data then we wait using
this future object we do some other
stuff in the meantime finally we hear an
event and go back to what needs
finishing off so concurrent dot futures
also allows me to wait on events and a
guess a think you and tornado take this
one step further because it's all
happening in one Fred rather than having
your across multiple threads and and
that the reason I sort of mention async
i/o and tornado is because essentially a
lot of the other frameworks that are out
there in Python for this sort of stuff
have fallen by the wayside a bit a thing
Kiyo's now in the standard library so
you'll obviously need to know that
tornadoes probably got the best
documentation and the most examples out
there out of all these libraries so you
probably end up using that one
so here's a little example of async io
so what we're going to do here is sleep
for 8 hours in 10 seconds what I sort of
mean by that is with 3600 parallel tasks
sleep for 8 seconds in each of those
tasks
yeah
okay when primary sorry our event
leaflet I'll maybe I'll survive
yeah I think these sometimes in the
dupes - notebook it's a little bit
difficult to to run this kind of task
but so typically I just switch to it
terminal so if I had it here so I've got
the tornado version here
so just we're sleeping for eight seconds
and then we come back but the point is
that in order to actually get back out
of the loop then or to hand flow control
back to the i/o loop then I'm using
these yield from this yield from command
so there's a few things the year so that
have to get right to create one of these
async i/o tasks we have to use yield
from we have to use in the event loop we
have to wrap the the function call in a
task and then we have to wait for it in
the right way and when we actually
inside the function we mustn't do
anything that's blocking
so then in Python 3.5 or 3.4 then
there's a new keyword async so what we
saw what you're going to start to see
around when you see a project to these
days if you start to see these async and
await keywords and really the two the
two things are effectively the same so
async i/o dot co-routine is exactly
equivalent to async death bar oh wait
so yeah that I guess this is the most
modern way to go about it
so yeah we always have to have this
co-routine it's wrapped in a task the
sleep function is also a co routine so
anything that you call insider function
for co-routine - then you got this yield
from in a wait
so it's sort of similar in in tornado so
again we've got this special sleep
command and we're using yield instead of
yield from in this case which is
slightly confusing I find but there we
are and then here at the bottom Luke run
think just means run one function in
this loop because one of the things I
found really weird about using tornado
was that you start setting up an i/o
loop instance and let's say I sleep with
with that i/o loop there then I can it's
still open and it's still running but if
I don't tell it to to start then I don't
know how necessarily to stop it so we
have features like run sync and run
until completed which allow you to just
run a standard sort of Python script in
in one of these async frameworks
so then now it turns out that we can
still do the same thing with Fred pool
executors and concurrent dot futures and
what's actually happening here is that
we're sending all these 3,600 things
into the thread pool and the CPU itself
is deciding oh yeah I've seen asleep or
the the way python is implemented on the
CPUs deciding are seen asleep I can just
go I can just move on to a different
thread because we've only got eight
processors that can only be do the
computer can only be doing eight things
at a time in a way then it's it's
switching between them intelligently and
actually when you run these two examples
whether the tornado or the thread pool
executors one the thread pool executes
is actually faster which surprised me
slightly but perhaps it makes sense now
the other thing to notice that in
tornado it actually does work under
Python two but the only way we can break
out of a co-routine in Python two is to
raise an exception so there's very few
and features in Python three which gives
us more options
so yeah there's loads more different
kinds of tutorials simple tutorials from
the e-rate dsds here so if you want to
read up to more about we may get time to
look at more of them later so yeah we
keep seeing this event loop thing and
this IO loop so what hell is it so it's
got all these different names message
new message dispatcher message prompt
run loop it's something that waits for
and to dispatches events so so I guess
one way to think about it is to think of
anything a look that that is producing
one kind of event and then we can move
on to sort of understanding what that is
at the system level so if we streaming
Wikipedia then we can actually read that
URL synchronously so here we've got a
nice simple request start get function
we can iterate the lines of the response
and we get back data print it out so if
if I go back to my example
yeah so it keeps it keeps printing more
and more output and it's getting back
so the question is is this way of
pulling back data from Wikipedia is that
really compatible with tornadoes I only
can I just can I just use something like
this and then push it into tornadoes IO
loop so that I can say right it's a
MongoDB without waiting for it say yes
and the answer is kind of no right this
this is this iterator is blocking so for
some part of the time that it's
iterating over that HTTP request it's
stopping the whole execution of that
particular thread which then in turn
will stop our IO loop from from turning
around and therefore if we try to use it
with tornado work we're going to have
some situations where tasks can't be run
so that means we need a non-blocking
read with tornado so this is to get
non-blocking read in tornado is not too
bad it's not too difficult we've got
this I think HTTP client we can run a
client up fetch method and then we
specify a callback to be called every
time that we receive some data so and
we'll get a very similar output to
previously except that what what's
actually happening here is that we're
receiving raw packets so that's raw
bytes of data coming back from HTTP
therefore we first got to encode them in
utf-8 we've then got to build them up
into our JSON objects which is kind of
pretty low-level in the noise
to be honest now if you're if you're
just reading straight from a socket
server then tornado has a method for
reading line by line but it doesn't seem
when it's HTTP so that means yeah we
have to add all this extra bugs to look
where the data look where a particular
piece of data started and build this up
into a JSON object check whether it's a
real JSON object or not and then if
there's some sort of leftover we have to
keep that in in the thread and wait for
the next piece of data to come so that's
what we self thought partial data part
is doing so that's great it works but
then how do we save those to the
database so we save them to the database
by in in our streaming callback because
this in this particular case we are in
the context of the tornado Tom Cote and
that means that we can call other
tornado carotenes just like they're just
like their standard functions so in this
case we're calling DB test collection
dot insert one so yeah you can you can
pull down this example and and test it
out
the trouble is though this is still a
lot more complex than the requests for
example I don't really don't really like
all this complex back and forth count
there's also two different callbacks so
we were hoping to write cleaner code
using futures rather than using tool
callbacks
so also you get this weird thing going
on with tornado is that or with async
Python and something to watch out for is
that if I create if I have an error in
my data
right so I just I just okay so now my
entire ipython notebook has has had some
restart and everything's crashed and
this is quite interesting because I that
means I've thrown an exception during
the system's IO loop and what's even
more kind of annoying really is the
stack trace because what does any of
this mean it's kind of how am I supposed
to interpret this okay so I'll go go go
go back I think I'll have to run that as
a single file I think
let's test
so yeah even what would typically happen
is that
okay so there's been a HTTP error and
when we look back through this stack
trace then we know it's come from simple
okay so we're we're trying to decode the
importers as ASCII and what what's
interesting what was really confusing
for me when I was first learning about
tornado was that hang on I've I've
thrown an exception here in data equals
import decode ASCII but then I don't
know I don't get any other information
about the actual function that I was
really running and the full stack of how
that exception got thrown so if we think
a little bit about what's going on there
the reason for that is that the global
IO loop is the thing that's running my
code and it's become detached from the
original place where it got called so
the way that this thing sort of gets
handled is the interesting one and
that's where some of the other
frameworks like that's distributed
handle it a lot better because what they
can do is natively package the exception
inside of the future so that when you
call your future later is when you call
the resort next looking for your future
then you get the exception back
so then how does AI Oh HTTP handle this
well yeah we have to install with pity
it hasn't got condor package yet it's
quite new the docs aren't that great but
we do get all the new fake language
features and suddenly we're able to do
these asynchronous iterators over the
response and it all looks very similar
to what we did previously using requests
which is quite quite neat really so I
guess one of the tasks for the end is
can you can you now marry those two
things up so thornado implements a async
i/o bridge so
and there's the acing there's these two
io loop classes that you can use instead
of the standard io loop and that will
give you access to both a tornado io
loop and an async io a io loop then you
can use tornado where it makes sense I
web sockets or whatever is better
documented for tornado or you might have
a framework that's already using tornado
but you can sort of attach and they
think IO IO look to it so what if we
learnt about they think HTTP well we've
learnt that tornado and async IO worked
really well for external HTTP requests
and things where something else is doing
the work
we always need this future to wrap
around it and where there's some sort of
blocking code blocking call then the
process pool executor can be used sort
of alongside of tornado so you can
sometimes have it or need a web
application with a process pool executor
inside it now ultimately though some of
those things aren't that recommended and
maybe that is why when we get to looking
at how I Python a Jupiter notebooks are
architected you'll see this usually some
kind of middleman between the async code
on one side and the synchronous code on
the other because that makes the whole
thing probably easier to test and you
can be sort of sure of yourself a bit
better
so the next the next one is to look at
this terminal clock so here I'm just
printing out the time over and over
again and I can sleep sleep for an
amount of time that adds up to a second
and keep printing the time over again so
the question is for later how do you
implement that using tornado and or
using an i/o loop how to keep printing
out the time to the console so the next
thing I was going to cover was how do
you run a task in Python and timeout if
it takes too long so yeah as I said
earlier it seems a really obvious simple
thing to do
but actually these further difficulties
in that both the process pool executors
and say yeah I think IO or tornado
they have canceled functions against
their futures but all that that does is
it throws a cancelled error against the
loop and sends the context back to the
loop so the loop can carry on running
but your process could still be dancing
away merrily deleting all the files on
your computer or whatever it's doing so
which I found really unhelpful and and
strange but it's all to do with perhaps
how Python is implemented in C so here
for example I can i can run until
complete
oh sorry
sorry
actually one from that one isn't isn't
it the next example is where we are
timing out a task with signals and this
mostly can work on them on UNIX but not
necessarily on Windows it would depend
on the situation so in this case this
time out decorator package allows you to
just wrap your function call in a
decorator and then timeout if and that
at least in this case the process has
been killed but you then ask the
question well have it is this a
definitely a scaleable solution that
will always work if it writes the kind
of killing processes at the OS level
like that is not great again another one
is then to kill kill the process using
again
yes Oh sub-process the sub-process
module has this ability to kill off a
process after a timeout so yeah that's
that's great so we've shelled out
affectedly and then then it can work but
then with all these methodologies we've
got possibilities of zombie processes
lack of control and yeah then we've got
frameworks that say they support task
cancellation but don't so I guess the
best way that i have found to do a
timeout and to specify when I'm running
the task is using Luigi so Luigi's a
task runner developed by Spotify and
yeah we can we can run this particular
task
sorry I forgot that burning
so we see that the task 1 task failed
because it timed out so if we then
reduce the the sleep time or increase
the time out to 11 seconds
and the task was successful
so great we've done a little bit of a
tour of them asynchronous Python methods
now we get back to our image processing
task
the thing is that we've seen with
Jupiter and with random crashes like
this often we don't necessarily want
tornado to be running the whole app for
us especially when is lots of things
that can go wrong so the question is how
can we okay I've got being find out okay
yeah I'll get my power pack in a moment
and how can we run this this
how can you take advantage of this async
HTTP but at the same time not have all
of the difficulties of tornado being the
main of the i/o loop being the main sort
of process that is running our task so I
guess what I'll do I'll just go get my
power pack and I'll leave anyone who
wants to download any of the stuff the
URL up here
so
so that distributed if the framework was
built on tornado and also Fred Paul
executor and it works similarly to the
Fred Paul executor but what it allows
you to do is if your it allows you to
scale from your laptop up to a cluster
and you've also got access to this
running i/o loop where you don't really
as long as you don't do anything silly
like raising an exception in the i/o
loop you don't have to worry about sort
of starting the i/o loop putting it in
and separate Fred and so on what that
means is that you can actually use
workflows like what I showed for
requests and Wikipedia without having to
worry too much about doing stuff I think
where you can still have a think as a
way of communicating your tasks between
the different workers so there's also
these data structures so if you're
interested in doing big data processing
with tools like desk which is quite
interesting in the sense that it gives
you the full range of features of Python
over a big data set over a distributed
system whereas if say I'm using PI spark
then but perhaps I can't run I have to
change my algorithm almost to make it
fit with the PI spark way of doing
things so it's quite interesting tool
you can also pass around queues so you
can take a multi processing queue and
you can pass it straight across a
cluster of machines
so the workflow is pretty similar now we
can either use the IO loop instance are
on the work client to pull down the
images or we can just carry on using
multi processing or multi-threading on a
particular worker so I've got the two
examples here
so we run out when we're running the
task on the cluster we just do client
dot submit run on cluster then it goes
away and runs it and then if we've got a
sort of driver loop for our application
we can use something called the worker
client which will go through all of the
tasks and run them from one of the
workers as a client to all of the other
workers and you see that the syntax is
relatively similar to what was done
previously using process pool executors
so we're just importing everything from
the previous file because that again
functions don't need to change then in
the case of tornado
then I what I found was but it was often
possible to get slightly more data over
the network using tornado because let's
well just because the way web servers
work really you're sending if you're
sending ten requests that want to begin
with you're probably overloading the web
server a bit but tornado by definition
is never sending all of the requests
exactly at once so the data starts to
flow back to you in a bit more of a of a
stream but more or less they're they're
pretty similar although again there was
there was more messing about to be done
with the tornado way of doing things so
here I have to keep a thread pool count
for myself and so on because it's not
implemented as standard in in tornadoes
async HTTP clients
so then sort of getting towards the end
now with we're looking at how do jupiter
notebooks work so as the hawk said
earlier then we've got a number of
different systems going on we've got the
browser the notebook server where is
this WebSocket communication we've got
the kernel well got and 0nq
communication which is again they're all
both WebSockets and 0 mq you can think
of them as working very similarly to the
Wikipedia example excepting in their
two-way communication as well so the
point is that the single threaded nature
of tornado makes it ideal for keeping
all these different browser tabs up to
date but then again if you have one
little bit of latency in any of the
system then you can very quickly get
overrun so one little bit of disk latent
of them blocking in the functions that
you in cooling
so the next example is tornado VD
printer
so on 4 8 8 8 9 so we see start and then
after a short while we see finish and so
that's one HTTP request that I'm writing
to slowly in my own time and there and
that's very similar to the way
WebSockets work but I just wanted to
create a very simple example to show you
that this this is really relatively easy
to do in tornado where as in any other
Python web framework like flask etc that
runs off where you WSGI you obviously
can't do this kind of streaming request
absolutely
so the final sort of thing is this uber
simple WebSockets repository so I wanted
to show you this because this was the
first time I'd really seen a really
simple
WebSockets example in tornado to sort of
get you going to get you understanding
it so what they've done here is say
right we're not going to we're not going
to render the HTML even we're just going
to show you how this was simple as
possible WebSocket handler work and how
does that connect up to JavaScript so
what's happening here is that the
WebSocket is sending the values with
this function here we've got an open
function so effectively we're opening an
eye only when someone comes and and
connects we're opening a periodic
callback per user who comes and connects
to our web server then we're sending
back from data every two seconds
and then we can just browse to wherever
you've pulled that repository to using
the file colon slash slash URL because
we just got a simple HTML file so and
every two seconds our graph gets updated
so this is just hopefully the simplest
way for anyone who's never really used
the WebSocket before to understand how
these things work and how to make a
really simple real-time dashboard then
we also have a little one notification
so I'll just I'll just go I guess I'll
go through the summary and then if you
want we'll we'll sort of finish there
and then you can play around with some
of the examples hopefully so we've
learnt how to use process pool executor
and thread pool executors to run tasks
and they can watch the status of these
futures we've learned how to make these
HTTP requests asynchronously we've
learned how to follow the streaming API
from Wikipedia have time out the running
of a function and then we've looked at
how you can combine this I think HTTP
with processing on multiple machines but
I think probably the main reason you'll
end up using asynchronous frameworks is
for messaging etc so those are probably
the best
and applications for this so guests like
to thank cigar me for letting the
Buddhist matthew rock clean so here only
this oppose is a real nice story in a
sense that I came to dust just beauty of
never having used tornado before and I
was actually starting to contribute some
things to the documentation and making
lots of mistakes and Matthew really
encouraged me and that that was so cool
cos and I would say to anyone who's
never made a open-source contribution if
you at some point got frustrated with a
piece of documentation try to correct it
yeah you'll probably get it wrong and
they might correct you and but everyone
will have that won't be a problem
you know the send your pull request
you'll get to know some people and you
will actually learn more about the
frameworks that you're using so yeah and
obviously if anyone's interested in like
using Sagami for generating machine
learning data sets or other applications
we've got loads of images and data come
and talk to me if you want to work for
us in Oxford come and talk to me and
yeah just one last little demonstration
say you see - in the browser so yeah any
any questions and any particular I want
that you want to drill into a bit more
yes in that case well oh yeah so it's
still service isn't it true that the
core regimes are much smaller footprint
than Castro closer to that's one of
things yes ins angeles origins feel like
order of magnitude of time absolutely so
as we're moving and i think this becomes
I've obviously done my tests on a really
powerful laptop and as we're moving
towards a situation where typically
you're running on maybe half a CPU on a
docker container they naturally getting
the most out of your network and the
most out of your CPU like that and
running on once what can you do the most
in one thread becomes relevant yeah it
is I think it all depends on exactly
what you're doing when it comes to
latency and so forth then WebSockets
will always win rate so and any kind of
socket based communication we always win
but what I suppose I was trying to get
across was that there's so many things
that you might try to do with tornado
just because but actually concentrating
on those things maybe it's more relevant
I'm not sure
okay thanks guys
[Applause]